أعتقد أنه من المحتمل أن ترى ورائي
أننا في سوق يسود إحساس
بالحياة الطبيعية في شوارع المدينة ،
فلا يوجد نفس النوع أو
أي شيء يقترب من مستويات الفوضى
والعنف التي رأيناها تحدث
خلال تلك  مشاهد مؤلمة للقلب العام الماضي ،
لكن تجربة التغيير أدت أيضًا
إلى انخفاض حقيقي في مستوى
المعيشة هنا ، ويقاتل الكثير من الناس
الآن لوضع الطعام على الطاولة ،
وتقول الولايات المتحدة إن ما يقرب من نصف البلاد
في دولة
تقول لجنة الإنقاذ الدولية إنه
بحلول النصف الثاني من هذا العام ،
يعتقدون جيدًا أننا الآن في
النصف الثاني من هذا العام ، سيعيش أكثر من 90 في المائة
من الناس تحت
خط الفقر وهذا
لعدد كبير من الأسباب جزئيًا  بسبب
العقوبات وتجميد
أه الاحتياطيات الفيدرالية
الأفغانية بعد تولي طالبان السلطة جزئيًا بسبب
أزمة الغذاء جزئيًا بسبب التضخم
ولكن ما تراه عندما
تتجول وأريد فقط  تظهر لك قليلاً ،
حيث أننا هنا في هذا السوق ،
يمكنك أن ترى أن هناك طعامًا هناك
طعام يمكنك شراؤه من أكشاك السوق
ممتلئة ، لكن المحادثات التي
أجريناها مع البائعين توضح
أنه بالنسبة للأعداد الكبيرة  غالبية الناس
أصبح هذا الطعام باهظ الثمن ، لذا
فقد أخبرني هؤلاء البائعون أن الطحين قد تضاعف
في سعر زيت الطهي والذي من الواضح أنه
أحد الضروريات الأساسية قد
تضاعف في السعر وهذا ليس
حتى قبل أن تبدأ في الحديث عن
التغييرات الحقيقية للغاية  وأصبح الأثر
الذي تركوه مثل طالبان
أقوى تدريجياً في تطبيق رؤيته
أو نسخة الشريعة